- Looking to the future years
you've been open about not wanting kids.
So is this still a thing?
- Yes.
- Okay.
You say hard yes.
- I still don't want kids, yeah.
(Kelly laughing)
- Why?
Like you just never saw yourself as a dad
or you just like your time?
- It doesn't seem that fun.
(audience laughing)
- I can see how it seems that way.
- Yeah.
It really does not, it doesn't seem fun.
And most of my friends who
are parents, God bless them,
spend a lot of their time talking about
how much they don't like having kids.
And what me and my wife spend
a lot of time talking about
is how much fun stuff we can do
because we don't have kids.
- I think that that's
actually pretty rad though
because I never wanted kids.
Like whenever before I met
my ex and then he had kids,
and I was like, oh, this is kind of cool.
- Yeah.
- I was like, and I got
to kind of experience it.
- Yeah, that seems like
a good version of it.
- So then I ended up having kids because
and then, so I would, I wouldn't say
it's like the most fun job
'cause it's like overwhelming.
- [Seth] Yeah.
- But it's a beautiful thing
and it's like nothing cooler for me.
But I will say though,
I think it's important
because people always used
to pressure me about it.
- [Seth] Yeah.
- About marriage and about
having kids and like,
it's like not everybody,
that's not everybody's
dream is to do that.
- No, and a lot of people I think-
- I just think it's
important you say that.
- Yeah, a lot of people have kids
and they don't even think about it.
- Oh my God.
We call those people
that have accessories.
- Yeah, yeah.
Or they just think that's
the next thing you do in life
is you have kids and then they look back
and they were like, "I
didn't have to have kids?"
- No.
My friend was like that's a person
that has a kid as an accessory.
And I'm like, that's not,
that's a lot of therapy in the waiting.
But anyway.
- Yeah, but you don't need kids.
There's so many kids.
- I know.
And that's the thing too.
Yeah.
- Who looks at all the kids out there
and thinks, "I wish they were more kids."
(Kelly laughing)
- I guess anybody that wants kids.
- Yeah, not me.
- I think that's cool.
And your wife is the same way, right?
- She does not want kids, no.
- Yeah.
- We get a lot of, I don't know.
I know people describe having kids, yeah,
as like brief glimmering moments of beauty
amongst a sea of pain.
It kind of, whereas not having kids
it's just lovely all the time.
There's none of that.
It's just great all day.
I'm never like, "I wish I had kids
and I'm missing something
by not having them."
I'm more am doing stuff all the time
where I look over at my
wife and she looks at me
and we're like, "If we had
kids, we couldn't do this."
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- This wouldn't even
remotely be on the table.
- No, that's why--
- We couldn't do any of
this stuff if we had kids.
- People with kids, that's
what we call me time.
- Oh yeah.
- You have to carve it out.
- All the time is me.
Why would I, who, why
wouldn't it be me time?
Who, what?
It's us time.
We do it together, we
wanna spend time together.
- I think that's really awesome
and I think it's so cool.
- [Seth] Yeah.
- To not pressure people and enjoy.
- No, I think there should be more voices
of that you don't need to have kids.
- Reason?
- Yeah.
You don't need to have kids.
Also, like, won't the world
not be here in 30 years?
(Kelly laughing)
- Aren't we all gonna die?
Oh my god.
Well, I do love my children.
- They seem great.
- They're great.
- They seem lovely.
- I'll call you for babysitting.
- Exactly.
- You and your wife would love it.
- We babysit.
Yeah, we hang out.
I love my friend's children
probably than they do
it seems some of the time.
(Kelly laughing)
- You get to play with 'em, hand 'em back.
It's the best.
It's like a grandparent or
an aunt or an uncle, yeah.